the US and it's on May 16th and we have
this book that we're going to focus on
over the next hour American terrorist
Timothy McVeigh in the Oklahoma City
bombing the two authors are joining us
live from Buffalo New York this morning
where they work as news reporters on the
left is Dan Hrbek and on the right Lou
Michelle good morning folks
mortal Louie she'll talk to us first ten
days out now from this execution we know
a lot of people have been reading this
book it's way up on the New York Times
bestseller list but for those who
haven't read it what new and interesting
perspective on this whole case and on
Timothy McVeigh can you share with us
well Paul it really provides a window
into Timothy McVeigh's mind I don't
think at least in this country we've
never had a book that starts with the
day of his birth and basically ends with
his execution we we had a chance to
study his childhood and go through his
adolescence and really find out what
makes him tick dan Herbeck talk to us a
little bit about the process of putting
this book together how did it begin and
we know that you folks interviewed
Timothy McVeigh how who talked to us
about the process of how you put this
together yes
well Paul it all started with us
covering news stories on the McVeigh
case for the Buffalo News where we both
work and Lou and I had done a story
tracing the McVeigh family back to the
1700s in Ireland and that's what got us
going on it and as far as the process it
involved two lengthy visits with McVeigh
out in the federal prisons and then
dozens and dozens of phone calls most of
which were made by Lou and a lot of
times we would send Tim McVeigh
questions that he would answer us
through letters he was also sending us
all the mail that he received from the
public including news reporters
that he would receive in prison he would
package this up and send it to us every
month so we really got a interesting
perspective not only on what he had to
say but what other people were saying
about him as they wrote to him in prison
we will be joined with our by our two
guests for the remainder of this hour
and we'll begin to take your phone calls
in a couple minutes so we'll put the
phone numbers on the bottom of the
screen once again joining us from
Buffalo New York this morning at a TV
studio there Dan Hrbek and Lou Michelle
co-authors of American terrorist and Lou
Michelle why don't you tell us about the
visits to Indiana and your interaction
with Timothy McVeigh what did you find
well I I didn't know what to expect when
I first went out there it's we had a
series of four-day interviews in
Colorado at the Supermax prison and Dan
Hrbek had driven me there and I remember
driving through the foothills of the
Rockies and just wondering you know am I
gonna meet a Charles Manson somebody
with swastika on their forehead and but
I remembered what his family had said
you don't know the real Timmy and we
hope you get a chance to meet him
sometime I used to drive the long way to
and from work to attempt to establish a
rapport journalistically so that because
I knew that this story needed to be told
it just couldn't I didn't think it could
be told in a series of newspaper stories
and during the writing of it at one
point McVeigh said stop writing me I'm
not interested in a book but one of his
cellmates or on the same range was Ted
Kaczynski and he was working on a book
as well and I think that that McVeigh
really liked Kachinsky called him a
kindred spirit and I think that that
open McVeigh to the possibility over the
these years that I was writing him and
finally he wrote back to me at one point
and said I am interested in doing a book
and you live near me up there so fast
forward to driving to the prison I I
didn't know what to expect so but I
arrived there and it's kind of like what
his family said
don't know the real Timmy he's been
demonized in the newspapers especially
those supermarket tabloids and the first
thing McVeigh does is flesh this
million-dollar Irish smile at me toothy
blue eyes twinkling and he puts his hand
up against the plexiglass and the
traditional prison handshake so I put my
hand up as well and we we went from
there and he had said to me you know I
identified with him I'm Irish Catholic
and he said that's one of the reasons
you're sitting across from me I'm also
from his area because it was real
important for him to bring in the
perspective of where he was raised and
so he wanted me to have he wanted
whoever the individual was writing the
book to have easy access to his family
but we did interview 150 people and
Timothy McVeigh was one of them and he
talked about hypotheticals at first his
appeal was pending and he wanted to tell
me his story in hypotheticals and then
at some future point perhaps turn it
around said well everything I've told
you is true so the first day of these
four seven our eight consecutive
interviews that I did we talked in
hypotheticals and but mostly about his
childhood and he was direct on that and
but then the second day he asked me if
there would be any interest in the book
and I said that no interest from any
self-respecting publisher on
hypotheticals and he said okay I've been
thinking about it all night and I'm
going to you know tell you everything on
the record between us and if it comes
out before then it's on you so he was
basically putting some of the burden on
me that it would send him to the death
chamber sooner as it turned out he wants
to die and deed said because you're a
Catholic and I know you're against the
death penalty I hope that you don't try
to obfuscate my my planned deluxe
suicide-by-cop package dan Hrbek we'll
get to you in just a second but I wanted
to follow up with Lou Michelle exactly
how did this acknowledgment or
confession that we heard about in the
news recently come about how precisely
did it come about
I don't I'm not sure I understand the
question well when the news came out
that he actually had had admitted
acknowledged confess to this how did it
come out in in the in the interviews
with you well one of the first things he
said to me is I bomb the Murrah Building
and of course I wanted to know if there
was any remorse and he said no I'm a
soldier and this is why I did it I felt
I was backed in a corner by the federal
government because of Waco Ruby Ridge
and hundreds of no-knock searches by
federal agents
he'd been a pamphleteer and he'd written
letters seeking redress for all of the
what he perceived as attacks on American
citizens and some of them are bonafide
attacks and he in the conversation he
would clinically explain what was
happening and I think he could see in my
face that I was picking up that there
was no sense of remorse or no emotion
and he would stop the interview and say
look I know I'm not showing any remorse
or any apparent concern but I want you
to know that I'm a professional I'm a
soldier and that's why I did this and
that's why you're not seeing anything
right now
any emotion or anything like that but in
Reverse he did weep for the children who
died at Waco dan Herbeck talk to us more
about the children at the daycare center
there because there was a lot of
question in in the media and through the
book as to whether he knew there was a
daycare center there he also talked
about a high body count to make his
point can you elaborate on all that well
first starting with the high body count
Tim McVeigh told us that he he actually
was anticipating there would be many
more than 168 people killed perhaps 4 or
500 and he as horrible as it sounds he
wanted a high body count to make the
strongest possible statement to his arch
enemy the US government as far as the
children in the daycare day care center
he denies knowing ahead of time that
there was a daycare center
and I know that a lot of people think
that that's impossible they don't
believe that they're very skeptical I
can only tell you that if people had a
chance to sit down with Timothy McVeigh
as Lou and I have for many hours and
hear him talk about the bombing I think
they would believe his story about the
daycare center because on every other
aspect of the bombing
he's he's absolutely boastful and proud
about it the one thing he is embarrassed
about and regretful about is the the
daycare center because he he realizes
now that because of those children
killed in the daycare center the deaths
of those children have far overshadowed
the political message that he was trying
to get across with the bombing let's go
to the phones for our two guests Lou
Michelle and Dan her back authors of
American terrorists we go to Olympia
Washington first welcome to the program
oh thank you so much for taking my call
thank you for c-span thank you for
letting us little voices way out here in
a wilderness have a chance to get our
two cents worth in speaking to the
question I will not follow my mouth was
the name of that person that murderer
I would I would hope that our president
select arsenic loving president would
commute this person's sentence to life
to life for each and every person that
that foul person murdered consisted to
beacon still be to be served
consecutively right you know he's gonna
be made a martyr people of his ilk will
remember Waco and Ruby Ridge and now the
president of the bombing Society this
despicable person let him serve life in
prison and this is something he does not
want he wants to die
him serve life conversion and gosh I
just can't say anymore thanks let's go
out to Buffalo to our two guests either
ever you want to take that well I could
just say that Lou and I are both
Catholics and we both agree with the
Catholic Church's position on the death
penalty
we're both against the death penalty and
I know the Pope recently made a
statement that he asked President Bush
to come to give McVeigh life in prison
so he would have a chance to reflect on
what he did and think about it for many
years to come and I that life in prison
is a better punishment a more
appropriate punishment much that's my
opinion anyway Lou Michelle McVeigh
predicted as he wrote in the book here
on page 375 that under george w bush the
quote federal juggernaut will pursue
more death penalty cases in the years to
come
creating the need for death row
facilities on the east and west coasts
and new federal prisons in every state
talk to us about that part of the
conversation
well McVeigh believes that the federal
government has abated in its more
aggressive tactics in dealing with
fringe groups that break the law it
should be recalled that these groups do
break the law they a lot of times
they're not just singled out David
Koresh was if what we hear from his
followers was despicable he was a child
molester however having said that
McVeigh also believes that in time the
federal government will take up its more
aggressive stance he believes that where
the government is way over armed that
it's almost like a standing army the
federal and even local police he
believes that the posse committeth Act I
believe that's what it's called where
you can't use the military against its
own Samara consider syns has in effect
then dismissed because of the state of
affairs now and but some of that has
been promulgated by the fact of the
violence that we have within
our cities that was spawned by the drug
culture with drug lords running around
with ak-47s and such it's a collective
soup of a lot of violence in our society
that has brought us to this state and
McVeigh says there's a lot of the
government agents have too many what he
calls militaristic toys to use against
its citizens and the the judicial system
will just be burgeoning and there'll be
more and more federal laws carrying the
death penalty and we'll have more
federal facilities that are needed the
one in Terre Haute Indiana simply won't
be enough let's go to Fayetteville
Arkansas for our two authors were
talking about Timothy McVeigh who will
be executed in ten days go ahead
Fayetteville thank you so much the
proceeded fan and I plan to buy and read
this book also my daughter said she
wanted to read it my question and
comment is about Timothy McVeigh's
motivation and I would like to tell you
what I believe and would you then
comment on it I don't believe that
Timothy McVeigh was trying to avenge
Waco I believe that Waco was for him an
opportunistic catalyst but the real
reason for his deep disappointment and
resentment was over being rejected by
the special forces and his knee and his
fervent desire to show everyone that he
would have been very talented in special
forces that deep disappointment was his
real dynamo that was his deepest
motivation in Waco was just a catalyst
would you please comment thanks Dan her
back want to take that sure well I would
agree with this young lady a hundred
percent that that he was disappointed
about not making Special Forces not
making the Green Beret I would agree
with that but from everything we've
learned from talking to him
talking to many other people that know
timothy mcveigh i don't think that that
she is correct in her theory about that
being the motivating force behind the
bombing all you have to do is sit down
across from him and look into his eyes
as he talks about Waco Ruby Ridge and
the US government and it becomes very
clear to you that this was the
motivation for the bombing not the fact
that he didn't make Special Forces I do
agree with her it was a disappointment
and and it's it him it frustrates me in
a way because I feel like if he did make
Special Forces he probably would have
gone on to become a highly decorated
soldier and there would have been no
bombing in Oklahoma City
LaMichael talk to us a little bit about
the point in the book that Timothy
McVeigh was very upset when Congress
decided that he would not get a military
man's burial that he was upset about
that how did he rectify that act of
Congress with what he actually did well
he was upset because he felt it was
petty action on behalf of the government
he in prison had made phone calls out
and sometimes would make statements
saying yes I am seeking a full military
honors burial and they'll have to do
that because I am a veteran and but the
bottom line was he never intended that
he was just baiting them it was another
cat mouse game he was playing with the
government and he was kind of surprised
that Congress would actually go and
enact a separate piece of legislation
for him but as it turns out Congress
enacted a few pieces of legislation
directed specifically at Timothy McVeigh
allowing victims to watch the trial
proceedings at a telecast to an
auditorium in Oklahoma City and a couple
other items McVeigh had never had any
intentions of being buried in a military
cemetery he had severed his relationship
with the
government long before that let's go to
Tacoma Washington for Dan Hrbek and Lou
Michelle hello Tacoma this is not Dan
Hrbek no no no those are our two guests
Tacoma Washington I'm sorry yes I just
wanted to make a statement I do agree
with McVeigh's motivation but not his
actions his actions are not justified
okay thanks let's go to Eureka South
Dakota yes you say you you interviewed
150 different people I was curious if
you have interviewed Carroll how not
Diane Sawyer of ABC primetime
interviewed Carroll how it was the
undercover agent for the be ATF and she
had infiltrated the Aryan Nation which
was done in Elohim City and she had
warned the 80s that these people there's
a number of people there one of the main
people's Andrews Strasse Meyer we're
advocating the bombing of the Murrah
Building and they were going to bomb it
on April the 19th where her handler
which was Angela Finley the only 22
years old she felt gee these people
maybe should be arrested and she put out
of arrest warrants for him and before
they were executed the FBI came in and
stopped the arrest because they said
they had bigger fish to fry you know
with the enlighted what's happening with
the FBI and there was a 1,000
fingerprints that this came out during
the trial one of the FBI agents had
admitted there were 1,000 fingerprints
that were not processed and these
fingerprints came from McVeigh's car his
motel room and also from the Ryder truck
where he and two other people rented
turds and writer truck and I was curious
if you interviewed any of those people
well we did try to talk to Carol how she
wasn't reachable to us but we did speak
to her attorney I have looked at
hundreds and hundreds of pages of
documents about Carol how documents that
I'm sure most people who voice opinions
about Carol how heaven looked at these
court documents Carol ha
is a troubled woman she would probably
admit that to you she's had a lot of
problems in her life she was not an
agent
she didn't actually work she wasn't a
sworn agent for the ATF she was a an
informant that was paid for a brief
period of time to spy on people and try
and come up with information about Gun
Runners Carroll Hall claims to have seen
Timothy McVeigh at a religious compound
once very briefly from about 70 feet
away and no one else has ever confirmed
her story we did look into her story and
I don't see any proof there there's all
kinds of theories that have been floated
about this bombing anything from militia
groups being involved to Arab terrorists
to the US government itself bombing the
building which I I think is outrageous I
don't believe there's any truth to these
by theories the people who have come up
with all these theories there's a huge
difference between us and them they have
never talked to the bomber they've never
talked to the mastermind of this bombing
so I beg to differ on those theories I
don't think there's any accuracy to them
we'll continue to take a look at photos
from this book American terrorists as we
continue to take phone calls here's one
of the photos a surveillance
surveillance camera photograph showing
McVeigh's Ryder truck passing by the
Regency Towers Apartments in Oklahoma
City minutes before the Murrah building
was bombed and you can see that it was
at 8:57 a.m. Eastern time the bombing
occurred just a couple minutes later we
have a call from Joplin Missouri hello
good morning I'm a Catholic too and
quite frankly this animal the day he
said he wanted to die and he waived his
rights this country gives people every
chance in the world to exonerate
themselves
and appeal I think they're wasting the
taxpayers money I don't think his name
should be mentioned in public anymore he
should have been taken out in the back
of the courthouse a minute he gave up
his rights and said he wanted to die he
should have shot him and save the
taxpayer a lot of money
any thoughts from our guests out in
Buffalo well
that gentlemen is certainly entitled to
his opinion he did talk about this
country gives every right and I think
it's important to realize that if we are
a civilized society we don't take
somebody out in the back of the
courthouse and shoot them stick their
head in a well and drown them like a rat
I think we need the due process of law
without that where is uncivilized is
countries that just have no respect for
human life Dan Herbeck not sure if you
saw this story yet today because it came
out yesterday it's in the Washington
Post in today's version the headline
says Vidal's role at McVeigh execution
is decried writer will serve as inmate
witness relatives of Oklahoma City
bombing victims were upset that the
Bureau of Prisons will permit Timothy
McVeigh to name celebrity author gore
Vidal is one of his quote friend
witnesses to his execution Fidel intends
to write an article for Vanity Fair
quote we're letting this thing get so
out of hands that Tom Kyte who
stepdaughter died in the bombing it's
just ludicrous what do you think about
that claiming all of this is just making
it ludicrous well Tom Kyte is a
gentleman that Lou and I have complete
respect for we know him in Oklahoma City
as far as McVeigh naming his own
witnesses I know that upsets people in
Oklahoma City and maybe maybe many other
people but the man is being put to death
and the fact is that the way the rules
are written he has the right to invite
several people of his choosing to the
execution and unless the law has changed
and and you know the the unless that is
changed completely and and he's not
allowed to have witnesses then that's
the way it's going to be he
he could have invited his own family
which which a lot of people would have
expected but I think McVeigh is trying
to shield his father and his sisters and
his mother from having to see him die so
what he has done in the alternative is
invite other people like his lawyers and
mr. Vidal Lew Michele you are named in
this article as one of the witnesses
identified by mr. McVeigh are you going
to be one of these witnesses I expect to
be one of the witnesses yes why would he
want you to be there and why would you
want to be there well we did write the
book on his life and the Oklahoma City
bombing and I've been covering Dan and I
have been covering this story since the
day it happened or a couple of days
after when he was identified as a
principal and the bombing and from that
perspective as a news person as a
biographer I would want to see it
through to the end now on to your next
question I don't relish seeing anyone
die I've been a police crime reporter
for twenty nearly 25 years and I've seen
some ugly things in you know poor
neighborhoods have seen people gun
victims lying on the ground and on a
personal perspective I just think it's
the most horrible thing we can do as a
society it's legitimized homicide
however if this is what we choose to do
as a society in our society of laws I
think it needs to be open to as much
public scrutiny as absolutely as pot as
as much as possible I'm not in favor of
televising it I know Timothy McVeigh
responded he knew that people would want
to have a closed circuit it down to an
auditorium in Oklahoma City so he
responded by saying let's broadcast it
on a national television network and he
wants to she says if we're going to do
it he took the position well let's show
the public order
so about I don't think we should do that
I think we'll drop a several notches in
our civil ways and they're so little
civility in our society I mean the TV
has become such a a mode for our
fascination our our endearment toward
violence in the entertainment industry
why would we want to take this venue we
also use for news and show a barbaric
act so I will be there to see the story
through to the end and just witness it
and very briefly are there are
provisions by the Justice Department for
a closed-circuit broadcast is that
correct yes there are and I can having
said everything I just said I can
understand how the victims feel and I
think Timothy McVeigh respects and if
anything McVeigh understands their anger
and indignation in in the book we say he
would have understood if somebody had
jumped over the rail in the courtroom
and gone at him that's something he
would respect and so he he understands
the need for vengeance and that's
something he respects and vengeance
apparently is a cornerstone revenge is a
cornerstone of the American criminal
justice system and in other societies
just not to as great a degree let's go
to Tallahassee Florida good morning good
morning
I wondered since these gentlemen spent
several hours with Timothy McVeigh and
talked to him many people in the public
feel that he should live with this crime
for the rest of his life and suffer the
guilt and consequences of his actions
because they feel that he is not
responding properly to the preciousness
of his act but the general public's
perception is that he is insane to have
performed such an atrocious act on the
public is that these gentleman's feeling
that the relying of reasoning that makes
they followed that caused him to
perform this act is a calculating way to
carry out his objective which is
illogical to the rest of us does that
make him does that make it a good reason
to kill him since he doesn't seem like
he will ever absorb the impact of what
he's done
thank you well I think that it would be
a lot easier in a way for all of us to
deal with the the issue of Timothy
McVeigh if if we could just say that we
thought he was insane and we could just
push him off to the side a crazy man a
monster the fact is if as we talked to
Timothy McVeigh and as his psychiatrists
talked to him they all agreed with Lou
and I that his mind is crystal clear he
knows exactly what he did he knows
exactly why he did it
he's loosened he's not he's not a crazy
man he as far as what would be a more
appropriate punishment you know again
I'm against the death penalty and I
think a person should have time to sit
and think about what they've done I
would like to say something as well go
ahead Louise Young okay it would be so
easy for us just to dismiss him as a
flatline monster without a personality
but our book does humanize Timothy
McVeigh and it doesn't glorify him it
gives the facts in a very
straightforward manner and some of the
reviews written about the book they said
we had unadorned prose we didn't analyze
him but we we put out the information
that we received from him from the
hundred and forty nine other people
including his psychiatrist three mental
health experts interviewed him and
declared that he was sane enough to
stand trial the point we wanted to
accomplish in writing this book was a
public service for people who are
much smarter than Dan and I school
psychiatrists law enforcement officials
school principals teachers we wanted to
put out the information so that perhaps
they could pick up clues on white
Timothy McVeigh did this our society
right now is suffering from all of these
high-profile shooting high school
shooters school not even in high school
some in lower grades and the best minds
in this country have been befuddled by
it no one has come up with an answer and
so we're hoping that somebody somewhere
will be able to put all of these pieces
together and I think that Timothy
McVeigh would like to find an answer to
why we've had this increase in violence
throughout our society he talks about
the need for children to have two
parents and this is by no means to make
him a saint because he does stand by his
action he feels it was the only thing
left for him to do but we as the rest of
society if we turn our backs and saying
no no the Oklahoma City bombing was much
too painful let's just move on I think
that will be to our peril and in a
society that has a free exchange of
ideas ideas we need to look at this and
hopefully somebody will find an answer
dan and I have just done our role as
journalists on the back cover of the
book a picture here of the Oklahoma City
National Memorial as we take this call
from Lynnwood Washington go right ahead
I don't understand how Timothy McVeigh's
anger towards the government relates to
racism is heyou racist thank you thanks
Dan her back one take that Timothy
McVeigh did he did explore the racist
world he he had a period in his life
where he he got some very negative
feelings about black people partly
through his experiences working as a
security guard here in Buffalo
also when he went into the army he very
briefly joined the KKK and what he told
us is that he read KKK literature for a
whole year and it wasn't what he would
wanted to to get into he he felt that
when he first joined the KKK he thought
it was going to be an organization
devoted to individual rights and and
also having something to do with gun
rights and he felt that if it just was a
totally racist organization he also met
black men and other minorities in the
army and what he decided was that he
really likes some of these black men
some of them he considered some of his
best friends in the Army and then there
were other black men that he really
didn't like so he equated that to the
feelings he had about white people in
the army he he said that ultimately
blacks and whites are the same that he
found good in bed and everyone look I
don't think he I don't think he any
longer has racist feelings I was gonna
ask my Michelle to add to that did
Timothy McVeigh have any kind of
religious upbringing did he speak to you
at all about religion oh we spoke
extensively about God and he's basically
an agnostic he he was raised Catholic of
course and was McDermott one of his
former neighbors who's a former nun
herself was one of his religious
education teachers and McVeigh I said
what if it's true that there is a heaven
in hell and he says well if there is and
I go to hell I'll have plenty of company
in hell I'll be joined by jet fighter
pilot pilots other military figures
throughout history that have declared
war on other countries or factions that
they didn't agree with and so he doesn't
think he'll be lonely in hell and if
there is something other than that he
McVeigh uses military terms because he
has embraced the that culture the
military culture and he describes it as
one of the best happiest times of his
life and in using those terms
he describes the hereafter as when I get
there if there is something I will adapt
improvise and overcome let's get a call
from the state of Oklahoma this morning
Midwest City hello hello you're on the
air I was just going to say that I I
agree with the caller who said that they
agree with his motivations I do too
I was upset about Waco Ruby Ridge Rodney
King and Oklahoma City bombing all these
things just doesn't seem to wake us up
we are a country of murderers we made
him a murderer in our military we teach
them to murder then we don't understand
why they use this against us I just wish
people would wake up in this country and
realize that you can't stop violence
with violence or murder with murder and
we can't kill him 168 times so I don't
understand people's hatred and meanness
in America now I just wish this country
would go back to thinking about being
under God thank you LaMichael how do you
understand the execution execution is
actually going to work on May 16th what
will happen well its plan its planned
down to the last minute they have an
execution protocol and that has been
released to the public and just in
response to that woman the execution
does in a subtle way continue the cycle
of violence and that's that's something
to think about but getting back to the
execution they will you know put him in
a on a gurney table something like that
and it has velcro straps on it that
secure his limbs and then they have
individuals not doctors but individuals
who are medically trained they're
trained to insert the needles in the
needle into his arm and there are three
different types of chemicals one makes
him unconscious
another
stops his respiration his muscles and
another stops his heart and they say
it's a peaceful humane way to go but
I've also heard that the individual
who's being executed is actually
drowning or in their expectoration
and/or being smothered and we don't know
if it's humane because nobody's ever
come back to say whether it is will he
be allowed any type of final statement
and is he interested in one do you think
well he has cited the poem Invictus it
was written about a century ago I
believe and I am the captain of my soul
or a few famous lines from it and he
toward the end of writing the book
American terrorist we had he had
contacted us and said that this is is
his final statement and he will he may
orally say it he is entitled to speak
before he is executed and he may say
some other things you know McVeigh is an
intelligent man and it probably won't be
a very long statement whatever he says
because he realizes that the electronic
media often chops things up and he's
very media savvy he's a he's a news
junky reads a lot of newspapers watches
a lot of television and understands us
in the media
Richard Moran calls Timothy McVeigh a
typical murderer Richard Moran is a
professor of sociology and criminology
at Mount Holyoke College he writes that
proponents of capital punishment have
claimed that McVeigh's execution will
help bring closure to the victims
families I only wish that were true I
suspect that most even those who
witnessed the execution will be left as
empty and angry as before not one of
them will have willingly traded the life
of their loved one for that--as McVeigh
the idea that McVeigh's execution will
restore the balance between good and
evil is an illusion unless mcveigh's
crime has somehow turned us into him
this kind of collective revenge is
almost always unfulfilled and generally
counterproductive as Peggy Broxton
who lost a son in the Oklahoma City
bombing has said quote you close on a
house you don't close on a death we move
on to Scottsdale Arizona now hello good
morning I think a quiet execution on a
gurney for this man is all together two
humane if anything he should stay in
jail with no TV with no newspapers with
nothing to read and sit for the rest of
his measly life and vegetate all right
thanks a lot let's go right onto Brown
Deer Wisconsin good morning good morning
how are you doing well how are you good
good I had more of a comment than a
question I don't think mr. McVeigh
deserves any more attention regarding
what he did in Oklahoma City he's
already received enough attention he
uses the Waco Texas as an example of
revenge against the government the
people in Waco Texas from what I
understand perhaps had a choice to seek
different alternatives they chose not to
the people in Oklahoma City were totally
innocent totally without warning had
nothing against Timothy McVeigh he
actually should have had nothing against
them and we know the results he doesn't
need any more attention he's already
caused enough harm and enough grief what
he should do is you should die in peace
or whatever and go to his maker
thanks Dan her Beck talk to us a little
bit more about some of the other folks
featured in this book in the photos one
of them here is uh Terry Nichols in
custody what's happening with him well
Terry Nichols has already been convicted
of assisting McVeigh in the bombing in
in the federal courts and he's serving a
life sentence with no hope of any parole
or
early release but yet the state of
Oklahoma has decided that they feel that
that's insufficient punishment and they
want the death penalty against Terry
Nichols so a second trial is is being
prepared there in the pre trial stages
right now you know I would like to make
clear that our book explains Terry
Nichols role in the bombing and it does
not exonerate Terry Nichols it makes it
very clear that he was with Timothy
McVeigh the day before the bombing
mixing the bomb and he played an
integral role in the bombing and all if
Terry Nichols as McVeigh says if Terry
Nichols was getting cold feet at the
last minute about this bombing any adult
can pick up a phone and dial 911 and
they could have brought it he could have
brought an end to this whole thing
LaMichael refresh our memory where was
the bomb made and we understand that
Timothy McVeigh had considered other
sites not just the Murrah Building talk
to us about that well the bomb was mixed
at Geary Lake many of the components
were stored in Harrington storage unit
and McVeigh spent his final days
preparing to mix the bomb he was staying
in Junction City at the dreamland hotel
where he had signed under his own name
he even drove the Yellow Ryder truck
there and you know that's all part of it
was all part of his plan to get caught
he left a series of clues for federal
agents and ultimately he he did get
caught so the morning April 18th Terry
Nichols was supposed to show up at the
Harrington storage shelter and help him
load on the thousands and thousands of
pounds of fertilizer in 50-pound bags
and Nichols didn't show so McVeigh
walked him up the ramp into the back of
the truck
cradled in his arms and then but there
were these three drums of the liquid
fuel that would be mixed and McVeigh was
trying to figure out how to do that and
he had figured out a way but Terry
Nichols showed and Nichols according to
Mick
he said can't we just sit in my truck
and talk about this for a minute and
McVeigh said no this is the real thing
going through with it and McVeigh says
that he had threatened Terry Nichols his
family - Nichols McVeigh never told us
exactly what the threats were but
McVeigh places Terry Nichols in the
truck he has Terry Nichols helping to
purchase material for the bomb and he
told us all of this only because he
believes that the state of Oklahoma will
put Nichols to death they will convict
him but by the time his state appeals
are exhausted Nichols will be in his 60s
and McVeigh says it'll be a lot like his
death a form of euthanasia that delux
suicide-by-cop package and so what kind
of punishment in McVeigh's words is it
to put an old man to death it's
euthanasia in reference to Terry Nichols
and what about those other potential
sites where else could this have
happened and how did it ultimately turn
out to be Oklahoma City right yes
McVeigh also had Terry Nichols in our
book scouting out buildings in Saint
Louis Missouri and he has Michael
Fortier scouting outbuildings he Michael
Fortier the other co-conspirator who's
been convicted and was the star witness
against McVeigh because he turned
evidence to the government was looking
at buildings in in Arizona and one of
the buildings that McVeigh himself
scouted out was with in Little Rock
Arkansas and this is absolutely chilling
it was a privately owned building called
the TCBY building in downtown Little
Rock and unlike the nine story
Murrah Building it was 40 stories and
McVeigh was drawn to that building
because he'd looked in a phone directory
and the ATF had its addresses at that
building so he goes to the building
looks in the foyer and sees a flower
shop and immediately he crosses it off
his list as potential site as a
potential site because he in his mind he
believes that it isn't run by government
employees it's run by civilians and he
wanted to limit collateral damage as he
calls it another one of the terms he
picked up in the military he picked the
Murrah Building
because it had so many when he looked in
the telephone book for that building he
saw so many federal agencies that had
that address on Northwest 5th Street
including the DEA and the ATF and he had
to have at least two of three law
enforcement agencies including the third
being the FBI in order for a building to
qualify and the other thing that he
found acceptable about the Murrah
Building it wasn't clustered with other
buildings nearby there was a lot of open
space and again that's the collateral
damage that he wanted to limit and he
also wanted a good photo opportunity he
called it his shot heard around the
world where he knew that the media would
broadcast images that print media would
write about the devastation and millions
perhaps billions of people would learn
about it and final aspect was the
architectural design the Murrah Building
had a darkly glazed glass facade and he
knew that that would go like an eggshell
when the fury of the bomb hit it did he
see and/or hear the bomb the bombings
the blast he he parked the truck calmly
locked the door got out took one last
look at it walked across Northwest Fifth
Street he's very specific about this he
did see a park police car as he was
walking away but he thought oh I hope I
don't get stopped bite he never looked
in the car to see if an officer was in
it then he got into a series of
alleyways and it was only then that he
broke into a jog and in the meantime
he's clicking off the seconds for this
two minute to two minute and thirty
second fuse the shorter fuse thinking do
I have to go back and shoot it and he
just rails at people who say he was a
coward because he says he was willing to
go back and shoot a bunch of explosives
he had piled in a front corner of the
bomb of the cargo bay of the truck and
but so he's counting off the seconds and
he's as he's slowed down to a walk again
and the bomb does go off so he was there
were buildings in the way so he could
never turn back in
the bomb lifted him an inch off the
ground some bricks fell he got hit by a
brick an electrical wire dropped and was
arcing and almost electrocuted him he
dodged that and kept going as we take
our next call we'll take a look at
another one of the photos in the book
this is the memorial in Oklahoma City at
the east gate at left 901 there it says
commemorating the last moment before the
bombing and at the right is that field
of empty chairs that we saw on the back
jacket of the book here again that's an
Oklahoma City of course Daniel Florida
thanks for waiting hello yes this is
Brock and Daniel and a lot of people are
calling in wanting to skin McVeigh alive
and I just wanted to express my view
that I actually I understand McVeigh
100% I feel sorry for the innocent
victims but what he did I understand why
he did it the government with Waco and
Ruby Ridge and and so many things I mean
our government even bombed the TV
station and Yugoslavia just to keep them
from talking our government is out of
control our cops are out of control
because of the drug war in her back
I could only respond to that by telling
you as I mentioned earlier I received
all of Timothy McVeigh's mail the mail
that he received from the public for for
over two years and you'd be surprised
how many people who wrote to McVeigh
agreed 100% with what that gentleman
just said they agreed with McVeigh's
anger and his outrage toward the
government but very rarely did he
receive a letter from someone who said
they agreed with the bombing the people
almost everyone who wrote to him
supporting his political views said that
they could not agree with bombing a
building and killing 168 innocent people
here is a photo in the Washington Post
lot written this weekend in the
newspapers on the pending execution of
Timothy McVeigh here's a photo of Peggy
Brock Strommen who we quoted before
whose son Paul died in the Oklahoma City
bombing she says she would gladly stick
Timothy McVeigh with the least lethal
injection herself dan Hrbek in lieu
Michelle we we know the great impact it
had on Oklahoma City of course what
impact do you think it's had on the
country as a whole
I I think everyone in America has been
impacted by this bombing it it it it
blew a huge hole in our sense of
security I work I cover the federal
government for the Buffalo News and I go
to federal office buildings all the time
every time I go through go into one of
these buildings
I'm scanned by metal sensors we're all
affected by this bombing the the federal
buildings in Buffalo now have barriers
built around them to keep keep trucks
from being pulled right up to the
building I don't know if this bombing
accomplished what Timothy McVeigh set
out to accomplish but it certainly has
scared the hell out of America Lou
Michelle do they still talk about this a
lot in the Buffalo area where you are
where Timothy
they grew up almost daily at the
newspaper the Buffalo News where we work
there are stories in the paper with
reaction wire stories
I think people in Buffalo overall feel
very sorry for the people of Oklahoma
City and they also feel very sorry
for Bill McVeigh who has been described
as the hundred and sixty ninth victim
though bill is not dead but they a lot
of compassion has gone out to Bill
McVeigh a man who is just simply the
salt of the earth
a hard-working retired auto factory
individual who is just befuddled by the
firestorm that he has been drawn into
but chained the changes in our
government in our country a hole has
been blown into our sense of security
into this land of the free where we live
we're not as free as we once were and
it's because McVeigh has torn a page
from his archenemy the federal
government and used the same tactics
that he says the military uses against
foreign governments that it disagrees
with Yugoslavia Iraq with bombings and
my hope and fervent prayer is that we do
not ignore him there was an individual
earlier night not trying to be
argumentative at all but he had said
he's just somebody we should ignore well
he isn't just ordinary yeah he had an
ordinary life before this but he's an
extraordinary individual with
extraordinary rage and we need to take a
look at him because why is it that
there's all of these angry young men
these and they're all white shooters
from the suburbs usually and going out
and doing these crimes that are
unthinkable and in our book we
discovered a common thread between many
of them one broken they're steeped in a
in an environment of broken family bonds
too they have failed personal
relationships they were bullied three
they were bullied as boys they were easy
targets the
they was not a very big kid growing up
and he was an easy target for kids that
it were bigger than him that theme never
left him the bullying theme and he
ultimately came to view the federal
government as the ultimate bully and
finally there's the the theme of
violence in our society we use violence
as a form of entertainment and as I said
before we're hoping that individuals
brighter than Dan and I'm more
insightful II somebody may be able to
put the equation together and answer why
this happened let's not turn our backs
on it as a country time for a couple
more calls we saw a shot of Tim McVeigh
'he's father here is a shot of Timothy
McVeigh with his grandfather ed McVeigh
the caption says that Ed McVeigh is the
only person Tim McVeigh said that he
loved ever this is at high school
graduation in 1986 Baltimore Maryland
hello oh hello
I'm on the air yes thank you thank you
so much for c-span I listen to c-span
radio as a true radio junkie it's a
fabulous service I can see by the two
gentlemen on your screen by your faces
and by the things you say you're very
dedicated dedicated journalists and I
can see the emotion is just swimming
under your faces I'm sure this is a very
difficult assignment you've taken on to
yourself and just to get this out of the
way I do find the timing of your
publication and your personal live
interview on TV today to be somewhat
morally suspect
I am very incensed at the attention that
McVeigh is getting we see pictures of
him dressed so nicely we see his baby
pictures he's a human being
I am anti-death-penalty I do not want to
see him put to death for a variety of
reasons one of which might be morally
suspect in me and that's wanting to see
him have to spend his life thinking
about what he's done to the very
beautiful young children whose pictures
are not on your screen today thank you
either of our authors well actually I'm
glad she brought that up because I think
some people have the perception that our
book is do
one of these quickie biographies that
someone rushes out and gets into print
just in time for a big news event and
that couldn't be farther from the truth
man
we we have been working on this book for
nearly 3 years and if you could go back
and check our publisher HarperCollins
listed this book about a year ago on its
upcoming books long before we knew we
had any idea when Timothy McVeigh's
execution was going to occur so I'm glad
you brought up the question it's not a
quickie biography it wasn't just time
for his execution at the same time it's
obvious to us that this this would be a
big story when he was executed because
this is the first federal execution in
our country in nearly 40 years and it's
perhaps the biggest crime in American
history so it is a big story and that's
why we're on this show today because
people are curious they are interested
and here's the book once again American
terrorist Amit mein obviously a lot of
people reading it as number 5 on the New
York Times bestseller list and we say
thank you to the co-authors Lew Michele
on the right of our screen and Dan Hrbek
on the left we appreciate your time live
this morning from Buffalo New York
thanks for having us thank you